[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily we
take you inside the courtroom for the
dramatic new developments in the derek's
chauvin trial a key witness breaking
down in tears as he watches the video of
george floyd's death
[Music]
is anxiety from testimony in the death
of george floyd causing jurors to feel
sick plus see video of george floyd
inside cup foods for the first time the
employee who flagged floyd's 20 dollar
bill as possibly counterfeit says he
feels guilty today if i would have just
not taken the bill
this could have been avoided
and we investigate our prosecutors using
the testimony from minors to try to seek
a higher sentence if children is
convicted just for the trial of derek
shovin and with us as always of course
is terry austin
day three of testimony in the death of
george floyd as the prosecution presents
its case
brian you are inside the courtroom as
the pool reporter what did you see in
here
yeah brian i was there for part of the
morning and part of the afternoon as
well when i got in i spoke to another
poor reporter and saw a bit of the fact
that one of the jurors actually had a
bit of a panic attack or an anxiety
attack as she described it she put her
hand up she stood up she put her hand on
her stomach as i was told and she ran
out of the court you may not have seen
it if you're watching the live feed you
really had to be there to see it
well clearly some powerful and gripping
testimony today any reaction to all this
from derrick sheldon
derek shovin has been cool calm and
collected the entire time i'm sitting
maybe
10 15 feet away from him the entire time
he's writing down notes he's
participating in his defense i can tell
you as a defense attorney myself when i
see
in between for example cross examination
and direct
he comes in and he's talking in eric
nelson's ear he's telling him i'm
assuming whether or not there's
something to cross-examine from this
witness and i can see eric nelson
nodding his head in agreement as they're
discussing this with the woman behind
them an employer a secretary of some
sorts i believe i'm not sure if she's a
lawyer as well but this is really a team
effort from the three of them back there
all right thanks brian we'll get back to
you in a bit in another powerful moment
prosecutors called an off-duty
firefighter to the stand genevieve
hanson filmed the incident on her cell
phone and can be seen on the city
security cameras the 27 year old first
responder says she heard floyd pleading
for his life when she walked up to the
scene hanson says she identified herself
to the officers and asked them if she
could check floyd's pulse when they told
her no she asked if she could show them
how to do it
to officer tau controlling the scene i i
spoke loudly enough that i i would think
that the
the other three officers would have been
able to hear me throughout the event how
did officer towel respond
um he said something along the lines of
if you really are a minneapolis um
firefighter you would know better than
to get involved
when you couldn't do that how did that
make you feel
totally
distressed were you frustrated
yes
on cross-examination the defense asks
askin what she meant by saying the
officer had their whole body weight on
floyd's body
when you first approached you saw
the complete and total body weight of
all three officers on phil i never said
all three officers i i
their body weight was
on him
the the two in the back their their full
body weight was seeming to be on him but
that's not something that would kill
all right and
the
but you you testified that that's okay
yes body weight yes body weight yes it
was on you would agree that your own
demeanor
got louder and more frustrated and upset
um
frustrated and i'm not sure is the word
i would use angry
more desperate
you called the officers right
yeah i got quite angry after
mr floyd was loaded into the ambulance
and
there was no point in trying to reason
with them anymore because they had just
killed somebody
cross became more competitive towards
the end as defense attorney eric nelson
asked the firefighter if she wanted to
review her notes from her previous sworn
statements
did you describe mr floyd
as a small slim man
[Music]
yeah it appeared
with three grown men on top if somebody
appeared that he was
small and frail okay
[Applause]
after sending the jury out of the
courtroom the judge had some words of
his own for ms hansen
we are outside the hearing of the jury
ms hanson i'm advising you
do not argue with counsel and
specifically do not argue with the court
is that
are the cameras down no they are not we
are on the record okay
you will not argue with the court you
will not argue with counsel
they have the right to ask questions
your job is to answer them i was
finishing my answer
i will determine when your answer is
done okay
and so do not argue with the court do
not argue with counsel answer the
questions do not volunteer information
that is not requested
the attorneys for the state have
redirect
they can ask you questions if they think
that certain things were left out okay
it is council's prerogative to ask you
leading questions and for you to answer
those and not
volunteer additional information are we
clear on this okay
terry is it unusual for a judge to
chastise a witness like that
it's very unusual for the judge to send
the jury out and chastise the witness
like that usually you'll hear a judge
mildly admonish a witness to make sure
that they're answering the questions we
saw him do that with donald williams and
donald williams quickly complied here he
saw that she was still hanson was still
talking back to him and usually you have
respect for a judge so he wanted to make
sure he told her clearly succinctly that
you cannot disrespect me you cannot
disrespect the attorneys and so he sent
the jury out and he told her one on one
i think he did the right thing and brian
even with all that was she an effective
witness for the prosecution
i think she was at the end of the day i
think what the jury's going to take away
from this is maybe not the spat that
what happened back and forth the judge
as terry said did a great job of making
sure the jury was outside of their of
the presence of the court when he did
set her straight i think at the end of
the day though you have an eyewitness
and someone who is an expert in medicine
and and providing that medication and
service the jury's gonna remember that
it's gonna be powerful for the
prosecution all right thank you still
ahead on law and crime daily yet another
tongue lashing from judge peter cahill
[Music]
several minors have testified in derrick
sherman's trial about what they saw the
night george floyd died
law and crimes antoinette levy is here
to tell us why the state has called so
many young people to the stand anjanet
brian
all of those children testified that
seeing this was difficult for them it
was very traumatic so you can imagine
that testifying about it would be as
well but it's quite possible that if
derek chovin is convicted the testimony
of those children could have an impact
on his sentence
first of all
would you tell us how old you are
nine at that time memorial day last year
how old were you then
17.
one by one children took the stand to
testify about what they saw the night
george floyd died tell us what happened
after you saw the ambulance come
he asked the emblems had to push him off
of them did you notice anything about
what mr strauben was doing
with his body
yes at one point i saw him put more and
more weight onto him prosecutors filed a
notice last year to seek an upward
sentencing departure if chauvin is
convicted meaning they'll ask for a
longer sentence than allowed by law the
fact that the crime alleged happened in
front of children is one of the reasons
why a longer sentence may be sought the
judge can depart downward but he cannot
depart upward
unless a jury makes certain findings
former hennepin county public defender
mary moriarty says if chauvin is
convicted and the jury finds children
were present judge cahill could increase
the prison sentence but it's not a given
of course if the judge gives an upward
departure that would be a ground for
appeal
and the state wants to make sure they
have a really good record establishing
each basis for a departure
the reason we're even discussing this is
because minnesota is one of those states
that has sentencing guidelines which
means there's a range of sentences that
can be given while a lot of other states
have fixed sentences for certain crimes
or at least minimums brian thanks
angenet brian and terry are here let me
ask both of you starting with you brian
the children's testimony is very
authentic isn't it
absolutely brian ross it's hard for any
defense attorney to be able to
cross-examine a minor or even someone
that was a minor at the time you can't
really say their credibility is off
maybe their ability to perceive things
is off because they're young but i think
a really strong point is at the end of
the day the prosecution's going to be
able to say even a nine-year-old knew
this was wrong and that's something that
i don't think eric nelson or derek
shoving can argue against and terry eric
nelson did do much of a job in
challenging their testimony did he
he did not he didn't even cross-examine
two of them especially the nine-year-old
and i think he knew better and plus the
fact that most of the testimony that
these miners gave were really
corroborating information that they
already knew for instance the fact that
chovin's knee was on floyd's neck and
the fact that he did not move his knee
until the medics came to ask him to move
away so that information was already
known i think eric nelson took a
calculated guess and thought it was
better not to look as though he is in
any way badgering these young women
imagine that bottom line this means that
the sentence for uh derek shoving if
he's found guilty could be enhanced
yeah that's right ryan and there were
some other reasons that the prosecution
cited for asking the judge for an upward
variance that included the fact that
derek chovin was somebody in a position
of authority a position of power he was
a police officer and they say he abused
that authority and they also said that
they the officers including chauvin
treated floyd with particular cruelty
because he was handcuffed at the time
that this happened and you could tell
quickly the trauma the children suffered
just watching a man die in front of them
yeah most definitely you could just hear
it in their voices it was so sad to hear
them talk about this and especially
darnella the young woman who
took that viral video she spoke of how
she'd stay she stays up at night
sometimes thinking about this and
apologizing for not doing more all right
very effective testimony thanks
antoinette manginet levy coming up on
law and crime daily new video of george
floyd inside that stories
[Music]
a pr representative for one of the teens
who filmed one of those videos of
floyd's death landed in some hot water
with the judge
rachel jackson took a photo of the young
woman named darnella speaking with
minnesota attorney general keith ellison
on the hall outside the courtroom a big
no-no here's how the judge reacted once
the jurors had left the room
the attorney general was
talking to her and i just took a picture
to memorialize it for her so she can
look back on it one day that's all
not for public
consumption for sure if you're a media
representative it's very important you
understand
that courthouses have very strict rules
about cameras right
i'm sorry yeah
i know better than to disobey a judge's
order
uh i'll chalk this up too that you did
not you were not aware of the order i am
actually asking that you you must delete
the picture oh i offered to do that and
recall any
uh places you have posted it
so why don't you come out up here and
i'll give you your phone back okay
please advise anybody who else might be
thinking of doing this not to do it
no i will it's a lesson learned we'll
leave it at the app
so judge peter cahill quite the stern
task master tara do you think he let
that pr woman off easy
you know i think he took her attitude
and put that in perspective and he
admonished her but it was a mild
admonish this was sort of like a warning
meaning if it happens again it's going
to be more than a warning the judge
already ruled that as far as the miners
were concerned he did not want them on
video and he wanted to make sure that we
only used the first names and so taking
a picture of darnell who was a minor at
the time is really going against his
rule and he wanted to make sure that
this pr representative understood this
picture can go nowhere you cannot
publish this anywhere and if it happens
again there will be more serious
ramifications maybe he will hold her in
contempt or keep her from coming into
the courtroom so i thought he did a nice
job there you don't want to cross peter
cahill and brian the judge seems very
focused on keeping the lid on security
measures how extensive is it without
giving any of the details away
yeah brian i don't think uh giving too
much away but the judge i i agree with
terry the judge is doing the right job
here it's chaotic not only outside the
court but inside the court as people are
moving in he's got a lot of things he's
got to take care of i've seen plenty of
trials i've been in plenty of trials but
doing it in the middle of covid in such
a high profile way i think he's handling
it very well all right well when we come
back the crucial moments before george
floyd's death the new video from
[Music]
as we all now know the incident with
george floyd started in a convenience
store called cup foods an employee of
that store has now testified he thought
floyd was using a counterfeit 20 dollar
bill to purchase cigarettes
when you got back into the store
um
what did you do about you know two trips
out to the to the vehicle
we um told our manager that he still
refused to come into the store
and do you know what uh
the manager decided to do about that he
instructed one of my co-workers to call
the police did the
police respond to the store
correct
george was
motionless limp
and chauvin seemed very
he was in a
resting state
meaning like he just rested his knee on
his neck
he saw you standing there with your
hands on your head for a while correct
correct what was going through your mind
during that time period uh disbelief
thank god
okay why guilt
if i would have just
not taken the bill this could have been
avoided
another piece of powerful testimony came
from one of the eyewitnesses outside the
store charles mcmillan who broke down in
tears as he watched the video of what
happened
there was a mercedes mercedes-benz truck
on the right side with a police officer
standing at the door
so i automatic
made a right turn and pulled over
and what made you
decide to stop and pull over
being nosy you know just being nosy i'm
in the neighborhood i'm i'm
knows the person going on a conversation
that i'm watching you know mr floyd
standing he clashed over the back seat
of the police car and i'm trying to get
him to understand that when you make a
mistake
once they get you a cop it's no certain
thing it's being class spoke you're
going to go with them and i was trying
to get him to go i can't believe this
[Music]
mcdonald i'm not sure if there's water
brian that testimony from charles
mcmillan was so powerful we saw the
children now we see this man breaking
down certainly the prosecution is
putting together a case that's very full
of raw emotion
brian it's not just what you can see in
the camera i was there for that
testimony it's what you feel in the room
let me paint the picture i'm sitting
there and behind my right shoulder is
rodney floyd george floyd's youngest
brother in front of me i'm seeing this
witness testify and you can literally
hear the ticking of the clock it's so
quiet as he stops and pauses
everyone is feeling emotional keith
ellison is four feet away from me you
can see that he's feeling emotional he
got up and got a water bottle to the
prosecutor to hand to the witness
everyone at that point was thinking
about someone they lost someone that
going through a hard time i thought
about my mother who's fighting cancer
right now everyone was feeling emotional
in that room it was hard to be there but
i think it everyone got the message it
was powerful and terry austin given
those powerful emotions how has the
defense so far dealt with it what can
they do to undercut the power of those
witnesses
you know eric nelson has his job cut out
for him it is very difficult to
cross-examine a witness like that and in
fact charlie mcmillan was so powerful
that they all decided not to
cross-examine him there was a little
pow-wow in the defense circle and they
had a conversation and they came to the
conclusion that it just didn't make
sense to cross-examine this individual
plus the fact that the testimony that he
gave was consistent i will say there was
one issue that i thought eric nelson
might want to talk about as far as
charlie mcmillan was concerned and that
was the only conversation that we've
seen so far with derek tobin but i think
and to his credit eric nelson decided
i'm just going to sum up with that
information
and brian do you think there's a danger
of too much emotion could there be a
backlash from some jurors
i don't think at this point we've gotten
to the point where we can think about it
being too much i think we're right there
where it's appropriate enough because
you've got to remember and i think we've
talked about it before it's a ripple
effect these people all witness the
murder they may not have known it at the
time but they now know that that was the
last moment that george floyd had spoken
his last word has braved his last breath
and being
having to relive that was emotional both
inside the courtroom and when the
witness left outside the courtroom he
had to recollect himself it was
difficult for everyone it certainly
isn't terry the whole country is going
through a trauma watching this
that's exactly right everyone is
traumatized at this point brian
all right well thank you so much for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you